que mi vida y mi muerte sirvan de algo
estas son palabras que cambió el patía
habría dicho a su familia hace algún
tiempo y amaño alma con las recuerdo
esta noche en este discurso que dio
durante el homenaje nacional que se le
dio a este profesor de 47 años y que fue
brutalmente asesinado el pasado viernes
en un atentado terrorista fue una
ceremonia que se llevó a cabo aquí en la
universidad de la sorbona una ceremonia
muy conmovedora en medio de música y
también de poemas y la familia quería
algo discreto de ser de que hubo 400
invitados entre ellos algunos profesores
estudiantes miembros del mundo de la
política francesa todo el gobierno
estaba allí y también la alcaldesa de
parís en su discurso que fue bastante
breve de manuel marco dijo que francia
va a defender a los profesores tanto
dentro como fuera de los salones de
clase y que no van a acceder a ninguna
presión a estos profesores que él dice
son aquellos que crean republicanos
además de esto dijo que van a seguir
defendiendo la libertad
pero tratando también de comprender qué
es lo que genera tanta violencia qué es
lo que genera tanto odio pero no por
ello se va a renunciar reales ni a las
caricaturas ni al humor